whether you're after guys with bushy
berries a partner who has a passion for
classical music or you want to find love
for you and your peach there's a dating
app to meet your needs
in 1995 match.com became the first major
online dating site today there are
hundreds of sites and apps it's gone
from taboo to the thing to do but what
impact is this having on society
Whitney Wolfe could lay claim to being
the 21st century's most prolific Cupid
as co-founder of dating app tinder and
CEO of bumble her digital dating devices
have generated 20 billion matches some
people might say app dating has
completely revolutionized their life
they now found the love of their life
and they would have never in a hundred
years ever run into that person today
around 295 million people use online
dating services all around the world the
Netherlands tops the list with 12.5
percent of the population dating online
South Korea follows closely behind with
twelve point four percent in China one
app alone Momo has a hundred and eighty
million registered users you have to
think about what dating was before it
was limited to your social network to
the people you knew and the funny thing
about the way we act as people we don't
always branch out
we don't always expand our networks but
online dating has enabled people to meet
potential partners can further a few I
really do think it expands horizons and
gives you access to being with people
that you traditionally would have never
had the chance to really grow close to
one study by researchers at MIT suggests
that online dating in America has led to
more interracial marriages the
technology has also made it much easier
for people in minority groups to meet
each other
70% of gay couples in America now meet
online dating apps are also popular with
single middle-aged people looking for
love some argue the apps are breaking
down barriers' and changing social norms
Whitney Wolfe launched Bumble because
she wanted an app where women make the
first move
traditionally speaking in real life
women wouldn't have made the first move
they generally don't make the first move
because society says that's not the
right way to do it society judges them
for that for that and often times blames
and shames them for behaving in a
confident fashion despite the benefits
of online dating there are concerns to
meeting total strangers is risky fake
profiles are common and sexual predators
can exploit the site in Britain the
increase in online dating has gone hand
in hand with a rise in dating related
crime although the numbers are small
despite the growing popularity of online
dating the majority of straight couples
in America still meet new friends but
according to the projections of some
online dating companies 30 percent of
all relationships will start online by
2026 online dating is big and set to get
bigger maybe online love will conquer
all
you